[Musik]
ihr mögt Schnitzel im Restaurant kommt
das ziemlich oft aus der Tiefkühltruhe
vorgefertigt von der
Lebensmittelindustrie Sebastian zeigt
euch wie er spritzt Schnitzel
flüssigwürze und wälzt sie in billiger
nasspanade er weiß aber auch wie er
industriefleisch und gutes handgemachtes
Schnitzel erkennen könnt
[Musik]
das ist ein Geschmack den schafft kein
Lebensmittelproduzent nachzuahmen
nie im Leben
lecker die Industrie versucht es
Anbieter sind Metro Selgros und Edeka
Foodservice deren Schnitzel schaut sich
Sebastian genauer an Auffälligkeiten
entdeckt der direkt beim Hähnchen von
Metro
panierter Taler schneiden wir mal auf
komm
er ist vom Fleischstruktur auch nicht
mehr viel zu sehen das ist ein
Hähnchenschnitzel hier kann man so ein
oder zwei Muskelstränge erkennen der
Rest ist eine schaumig geschlagene Masse
kann man hier in die kleinen
Luftbläschen erkennen
ich denke mal das ist eher so ein Ding
was ganz gerne in der Bäckerei auf dem
Brötchen landet beim Schweineschnitzel
Wiener Art von Metro entdeckt Sebastian
lege Spuren von
injektionsmaschinen genau wie bei dem
klassischen Wiener Schnitzel aus
Kalbsfleisch aus dem Edeka Großhandel
kleine Nadelstiche wieder zu erkennen
auch das wurde injiziert und aktiviert
das Fleisch wird aktiviert mit einer
flüssigwürze ein Blick auf die
Zutatenliste bestätigt das Metro-Chef
verzichtet auf Ei in der Panade und
setzt bei seinen Schnitzeln für
Restaurants auf flüssig Wirkung
eine Spritze und Zutaten in Pulverform
das braucht Sebastian lege für den
Nachbau der industrieschnitzel er will
das Fleisch mit Salz Gewürzen Phosphat
Zwiebelpulver und Dextrose schmackhaft
machen
jetzt ich mein Schnitzel erstmal die
Spritze
und es geht los da raten Sie mal
kräftiger Schluck Wasser die Basis für
die flüssigwürze
ganz wichtig Dextrose sorgt für
Haltbarkeit aber auch für Stabilität
Dextrose ist ein einfacher auch als
Traubenzucker bekannt jetzt ganz wichtig
Salz
Salz ist auch ein Freund der
Lebensmittelindustrie Punkt 1 klar
Geschmack und das andere technologische
Hilfsstoff Salz sorgt dafür dass die
Proteine aktiviert werden und
dementsprechend das Wasser umschließen
und dass das nicht mehr so schnell
ausdünsten kann
mit Gewürzen und Phosphat rührt
Sebastian lege seine flüssigwürze fertig
an
die soll nun im Fleisch stehen Geschmack
verstärken
in Düsseldorf auf der Köf würde man für
so eine Behandlung richtig Geld bekommen
wir ziehen jetzt mal schön die Falten
beim Schnitzel glatt
dem Fleisch initiiert Sebastian lege
seine angerührte flüssigwürze jede
Spritze erhöht das Gewicht
[Musik]
das Fleisch wird mit Wasser gestreckt
und bringt dadurch mehr Gewinn
damit das alles sich rausläuft müssen
wir jetzt die proteinverkettung von
außen wieder so verreiben dass alle
schön drin bleibt und das geht am besten
in so einem Tumblr naja das war mal ein
Bierfass jetzt ist ein Tumblr das
Fleisch würde ohne weitere Behandlung
das zugesetzte Wasser wieder verlieren
die fleischwaschmaschine schafft es in
10 Minuten Proteine und Wasser dauerhaft
zu verbinden
natürlich Eis und bei der Rotation
schmilzt das Eis natürlich und gibt noch
mal einen kleinen Schluck Wasser extra
in unsere Schnitzel
[Musik]
billiges Eis und kostengünstige Lake
machen das Schnitzel lukrativ
[Musik]
es besteht nach der Behandlung zu einem
großen Teil aus Wasser und flüssiger
Würze
[Musik]
wir haben da so gut bearbeitet das ist
garantiert immer zart und damit ist auch
wirklich zu 100 Prozent im Mund schmilzt
kommt hier gleich der Kollege zum
Einsatz
die Maschine macht Schnitzel platt dafür
schneidet Sebastian lege das behandelte
Fleisch in große Stücke die
Fleischqualität spielt bei
industrieschnitzeln praktisch keine
Rolle die intensive Behandlung macht
jedes zehestück Fleisch genießbar da
kann man wirklich nehmen was man möchte
die Perforation macht alles zart dann
wird nämlich hier gedreht
und dann kommt hier
ein schönes
perforiertes Schnitzel raus perfekt auf
der Walze befinden sich zahlreiche
kleine Nadeln die ersetzen den Koch der
sonst mühsam das Fleisch per Hand
klopfen muss
das sieht doch gut aus
wunderbare Schnitzel oder
sehr schön
perforiert schön aufgerissen ja das
heißt man hat die Oberfläche so zerstört
das ist immer butterweich egal wann da
können Sie die Zähne rausnehmen und das
können sie einfach nur mit den Lippen
lutschen
einfache Restaurants arbeiten vorwiegend
mit der Friteuse die Industrie bereitet
ihre fertigen Schnitzel extra dafür vor
wir sind im Finale
das Schnitzel bekommt noch sein
Kleidchen und dann geht's ab in die
Tiefkühltruhe dann wird es rausgenommen
und zack im Erlebnisrestaurant auf den
Teller geworfen ein paar Fritten dazu
ein bisschen Mayo eine Champignonsoße
und so sind 12,50 in der Kasse
der wird natürlich nicht mit Ei paniert
nein
nasspanada heißt das Zauberwort Wasser
ganz wichtig dann eine Kombination aus
mehreren Stärken hier haben wir eine
Maisstärke ein bisschen Weizenmehl
ein bisschen Salz
ein bisschen Reismehl
und ein bisschen Maismehl diese Mischung
ist günstig gut dosierbar und benötigt
nur haltbare Zutaten an der nasspanade
bleiben die Semmelbrösel optimal haften
in der Friteuse gab das Schnitzel vor
zum Abkühlen bereitet Sebastian minus
196 Grad kalten flüssigen Stickstoff vor
ja genau so schnell wie so ein Schnitzel
paniert wird wird es auch gefrustet
[Musik]
perfekt so hat man den Garprozess sofort
unterbrochen und wenn der Schnitzel
von einem ungelernten Koch weil es ist
ja alles vorbereitet die Industrie hat
die komplette Arbeit gemacht in der
Friteuse noch mal wieder warm gemacht
wird ist es perfekt und sieht genauso
aus
im kriegsrestaurant haben die Gäste
Hunger auf die Hauptspeise
Sebastian lege will bei Ihnen die
verschiedenen Industrieprodukte testen
[Musik]
der Tag was habe ich übrigens
Hähnchen ich hätte gerne kalt Sebastian
leges Speisekarte ist groß es gibt
Schnitzel vom Schwein Hähnchen Pute oder
Kalb dazu Bratkartoffeln oder
Kartoffelsalat der ein Mann Betrieb zum
lustigen lege behauptet dennoch alles in
kürzester Zeit selbst zuzubereiten
würdet ihr mir glauben wenn ich euch
sage eure Gerichte kommen innerhalb von
7 Minuten
funktioniert bis gleich 10 Teller mit
unterschiedlichen Schnitzeln und
Beilagen in nur 7 Minuten Sebastian lege
meint kein Problem ich habe alles
vorbereitet zack einmal Schnitzel und
alle wollen sie Schnitzel
da haben wir schon mal die vor panierten
kartoffelbeilagen kommen auch direkt
fertig aus der Tüte
so schnell so viele Gerichte kochen ist
doch super oder
so ich mache hier schon mal ach waren
zwei einmal mit Bratkartoffeln einmal
mit Kartoffelsalat in die Friteuse und
ich muss jetzt ja nicht mehr viel machen
das Schnitzel kommt für gerade einmal
zwei Minuten direkt aus der
Tiefkühltruhe in die Friteuse und weil
alles tiefgefroren ist können die
Restaurants eine große Auswahl vorhalten
einmal der sechsarmige Oktopus in der
Küche und 100 Essen gekocht ganz alleine
die einzige Herausforderung für
Sebastian lege ist den Überblick zu
behalten
handwerkliches Können braucht er dagegen
nicht
das hier ist sogar richtig schön
aufgegangen hier ist so Flirt und die
Decken ich hatte das Schnitzel in der
Pfanne
pustekuchen Putenschnitzel ist auch
gleich fertig ich muss Gas geben
Sebastian lege erledigt tatsächlich die
komplette Bestellung innerhalb der
versprochenen 7 Minuten von kochen kann
dabei keine Rede sein schmecken die
Gäste heraus dass sie vorgefertigte
Produkte der Lebensmittelindustrie
serviert bekommen haben
na
gut ich habe gut gekocht sehr lecker für
sieben Minuten nicht schlecht oder sehr
gutes 7 Minuten schön saftig schönen
saftig das war eine Aussage die wollte
ich hören was würdet ihr im Restaurant
dafür bezahlen dafür dass das ein
Kalbsschnitzel ist 24 €
. das ja das kommt hin kostet das
oftmals du hattest Hähnchen ich hatte
Hähnchen was würdest du dafür bezahlen
wie war mein 7 Minuten Schnitzel also 7
Minuten ziemlich gut was könnte ich
gleich bei dir kassieren 16 17 €
die meisten Gäste würden für das
Fertigessen tief in die Tasche greifen
nur zwei schöpfen Verdacht
wie sieht's aus einer schnitzelfront
gruselig
okay sehr gruselig also hier nix heute
mit Trinkgeld ich glaube nicht ich
glaube das geht sogar zurück noch ich
glaube da ist der Schnitzel
schnitzeltier nur kurz in der Küche
vorbei gelaufen diese beiden zweifeln
dass sie echtes Fleisch gekaut haben
Sebastian lege löst auf es freut mich
dass euch das Schnitzel so gut
geschmeckt hat dem einen weniger dem
anderen mehr ob Hähnchen Schwein oder
kalt es war alles echtes Fleisch ich
habe dich selber gemacht es kam aus der
Tiefkühltruhe und die Beilagen ebenso
die Arbeit mit vorgefertigten Essen der
Industrie bringt Restaurants viel
gewinnen das Hähnchenschnitzel aus den
drei Kilogramm Karton kostet nur 1,40 €
pro Stück fester waren bereit 8 € zu
zahlen die Pute gibt es schon für 1,20
€. Sebastians gäste zahlen dafür 12 Euro
und das Kalbsschnitzel für 2,50 €,
kriegt Sebastian lege beim Test für im
Schnitt 19 Euro los
auf der Speisekarte muss nicht
deklariert werden ob tiefgekühlte Ware
eingesetzt wurde können wir das als
Konsumenten im Restaurant selbst
erkennen für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher im Restaurant ist es
schwierig festzustellen ist das jetzt
hier selbst gemacht worden oder ist das
aus industrieller Produktion ein Hinweis
darauf kann immer geben wenn die
Schnitzel alle sehr gleich sehr
gleichförmig Aussehen und die Panade an
allen Stellen genau gleich dick ist aber
gerade die Panade die erschwert ist
natürlich zu erkennen wie wurde das
hergestellt oder auch welche Fleisch
[Musik]
natürlich setzen nicht alle auf
convenience Produkte es gibt in
Deutschland immer noch viele gute
handwerklich vorbildlich arbeitende
Restaurants die verlangen für ihr Essen
aber auch etwas mehr Geld
ich würde mir wünschen von diesen Leuten
die das wollen dass sie eben auch
hinschauen und das unterstützen wenn sie
sehen da ist ein guter Betrieb und das
dass es Ihnen wert ist vielleicht auch
mal ein bisschen mehr zu bezahlen